[Music]
there's a photo a paparazzi photo that
appeared just the other day
it's huge shirtless can we put it up
again please because it's not photoshop
you're speaking into a banana as if it
were a telephone with an orange in your
mouth
there's no one holding a gun to you
making you do that
well i'll tell you
there was a few photographers around so
we had a game
uh who could who could get the most
stupid photo published and i won you win
yes you went hands down and uh did you
think
amazing i really saw this and thought
you've had some kind of mental breakdown
i was having one of those as well
you know what it's those moments though
that i really enjoy working with you
because you're actually really funny and
you know i know it looks like we hate
each other and a little bit of me does
unless you tell me
but you're actually fun to work i tell
you thanks
it's more fun when you hate each other
um
you should you now there was a lot
written about you simon that you uh in
the british tabloids they claimed that
you had some kind of mental collapse
recently what's that go what's going on
there well it wasn't a mental collapse
uh you were just uh talking into a
banana with an orange in your mouth
we have an actual photo of you
that is the dictionary definition of
mental collapse
as you can see there was somebody else
doing it yeah um oh that makes it fine
yeah no i uh you know what i did conan i
decided to turn my phone off for six
weeks my mobile phone this is in britain
you know in america i was in la at the
time they were just driving me nuts
getting all these crazy text messages
two or three in the morning uh and i
decided to switch my phones off focus on
work
uh became a little bit reclusive for a
couple of weeks but i i kind of i
thought it was like good therapy sure
and i would recommend it to anyone by
the way this was reported as you having
a complete mental breakdown yeah
were you alone in your apartment the
whole time
um were you naked and drinking red wine
constantly all right let's move on to
you tommy
no you you uh have a reputation for
falling a lot in concert is that true i
do and in fact i kind of i
kind of just fell backstage you just
fell backstage
what's going on or why are you falling
off one leg might be shorter than the
other that's just my theory but i'm just
well then you'd be walking in circles
most of the time
i just i'm really clumsy and i fall
i am i fall like almost every single
time i go on tour so it's i joke around
like it's not an actual tour unless i
fall in on scene we actually have a
youtube video i believe this is you in
concert from uh
recently and here you are let's take a
look you're you're having a good time
you're singing
you run
[Applause]
that's nice i like that you
you own it you owned it i should i kind
of have to do if there's 60 000 people
here you have to running really one of
my first concerts
and it was in front of like 20 000
people i was opening up for the jonas
brothers and i just oh my god i was
mortified and i went i stayed in bed the
entire next day and i cried oh
it was like my first time really being
on perez hilton i was like oh my god i
made it wait he's making fun of me
and then i and then i just i don't know
i started falling on stage more often
and
i just
wait a minute it became your thing yeah
yeah
that's my handle now i fall dear people
when they because you can see you're
starting to do this big run on stage do
your people now whenever you start a big
run but she's got here she's going down
she's going down
no sometimes it's just unexpected and i
just like pretend that i was trying to
go into like a knee slide move right and
really my fans are just like in the
audience they're like oh that's dimmy
right
there she goes again trying to play it
off one leg shorter than the other
but god